this month on the podcast you're talking
about neuroplasticity you mentioned a
bunch already
is there something you're looking
forward to
specifically like something maybe you're
fascinated
by that jumps to mind about
neuroplasticity
this fascinating property of the brain
yeah i think that
it's clear there's one facet of
neuroplasticity that
is very well supported by the research
data
that hardly anyone has implemented in
the real world
and that's the release of acetylcholine
from these neurons in the forebrain
called nucleus basalis
this is mainly the work of mike mersonic
who used to be at ucsf
and some of his scientific offspring
greg reckons own and michael kilgart and
others what they showed was
increases in acetylcholine this molecule
associated with focus
in concert meaning at the same time as
some
event motor event or music event or any
kind of
sensory event immediately reorganizes
the neocortex
so that there's a permanent map
representation of that event
and i i absolutely believe that this can
be
channeled toward accelerated skill
learning and my friend and colleague
eddie chang is
now the chair of neurosurgery at ucsf
but also a fine scientist in his own
right
not just a clinician he's doing studies
looking at rapid acquisition of language
using these principles he trained with
marsnick
it's clear we have these gates on
plasticity in the forebrain and they
are gated by nicotinic acetylcholine
transmission and why that hasn't made it
into protocols
for motor learning sport learning
language learning music learning
emotional learning i don't know i think
part of the reason has been
kind of cultural is that scientists
publish their paper and they move on
merzianic
talked a lot and still can be found from
time to time talking about
how these plasticine mechanisms can be
leveraged
but uh he had a commercial company and
so then people kind of backed away from
it a little bit i think he was
to be honest i think merzenik was ahead
of his time
and i think the timing is right now for
people to understand these mechanisms of
plasticity and start to implement them
also you know it all sounds like
becoming superhuman or optimizing or
whatever
all that yes but also what about kids
with language learning deficits or with
dyslexia
or just performance in school in general
you know i have a deep
interesting concern for the future of
science and mathematics and
in not just in this country but all over
the world and
more plasticity equals faster better
deeper learning
and if we don't do this i don't think
we're going to get the full
reach out of all the machine learning
tools either
because everyone talks about these huge
data sets and but those huge data sets
have funnel into
human interpretation i mean we don't
just like stare at the numbers and bask
right
so some the human brain i think needs to
leverage these plasticity mechanisms to
keep up with the thing that's happening
very very fast which is technology
development so that's a long-winded way
of saying
basal forebrain cholinergic transmission
and plasticity it
allows for plasticine adulthood and
allows for it in single trial learning
which is incredible
but how do we leverage that like in the
physical space taking actions or is
there some chemicals that can stimulate
uh stimulate neuroplasticity like what i
think it's the intersection of the two
i think it's being engaged in a physical
practice while enhancing pharmacology
it has to be done safely and this is
full of open questions this is the very
beginning
of it like like you're saying yeah a
pill that's safe
that increases nicotinic transmission i
mean i know a number of people that chew
nicorette um actually they haven't i
have a nobel prize winning colleague
at columbia not to be named um who
choose like six pieces of nicorette in a
half hour conversation with him
and he started doing that as a
replacement for smoking because smoking
is nicotine nicotinic stimulation of the
cholinergic system so smokers have
long known that it increases focus and
attention and learning
it's just that the lung cancer thing is
is a barrier
now i'm not suggesting people take
nicorette but it's clear that we need
better directed pharmacology but you can
imagine next time you go in for a
learning bout if it's really essential
you might want to stimulate the
nicotinic system if that's safe for you
again i'm a doctor so again i'm not
telling people to do this but that's
where it's going
until we start merging machines with
pharmacology and behavior
it's it we're just kind of walking
around in the circle over and over again
and it's going to happen
you